bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france comment est ce que vous expliquez
déjà l'effondrement de la monnaie locale
puis quelle conséquence directe pour la
population écoutez comment expliquer la
chute va finalement malheureusement ça
fait presque un an qu'on vit une des
crises les plus graves libanaise au
niveau politique au niveau social au
niveau même sécuritaire et bien sûr au
niveau sanitaire comme tout le monde
finalement cette chute finalement vous
avez parlé des 10 me l'un des mes livres
simplement pour que les téléspectateurs
suivent nous étions à 1 dollar à 1500
nous sommes aujourd'hui a dit me livre
donc c'est une chute du pouvoir d'achat
de plus de 75%
c'est une fuite du niveau des salaires
de puisque 75% d'un coup et ce si une
fuite des dépôts à savoir que les
libanais aujourd'hui tous les déposants
libanais ou autres libanais et surtout
les expatriés dans le monde qui ont mis
tout leur antre tout leur travail dans
les banques des manèges ont perdu déjà
plus de 75 % de leur valeur et même cela
devint la relaxe ils peuvent pas y
arriver
c'est une crise inédite c'est une crise
qui a besoin évidemment d'un plan de
restructuration totale ce qui n'est pas
du tout rendez vous avec un ministère
complètement démissionnaire donc
simplement pour remettre la situation
comme les cas mal et nous avons une
population qui a perdu 75% de son
pouvoir d'achat et en même temps à une
hausse des prix de plus de six fois
parce que finalement nous importons 80 %
de nos besoins
donc tout tout tout nous le besoin
viennent d'europe ou des pays anglo
saxons ou américains donc ça nous a fait
une augmentation de plus que six fois
dont plus que 600 % des prix avec une
chute du pouvoir d'achat de 75 %
évidemment ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
c'est invivable et on s'attend à aller
des 102 rue encore plus plus fortes qui
peuvent même devenir agressif parce que
la population pour la première fois de
l'histoire les malaises dont seulement
souffre mais afin afin pas de
médicaments pas d'hôpitaux et bien sûr
plus de services
c'est un climat général de colère qui
règne aujourd'hui au liban au delà des
clivages politiques traditionnels
écoutez les clivages politiques je vais
dire malheureusement nous nous sommes
habitués et je peux dire qu'il y aura
mais qui est même des tensions
politiques sur la rue je peux vous dire
que ces manifestations qu'on voit
maintenant à l'écran on peut dire
évidemment qu'il ya une partie qui est
très social et économique mais à une
autre aussi qui tirait par les ficelles
par les groupuscules ou des groupes
je dirais politique parce que finalement
ils ont je veux dire et des intérêts
communs
donc on peut dire qu'un côté il ya
vraiment la crise sociale et d'un autre
on sait que la rue finalement
n'appartient pas l'habitude aux
manifestants transparent mais la rue et
surtout les casseurs et autres
appartiennent beaucoup plus à des
groupes politiques donc la descente à la
rue d'habitude on perd tout contrôle et
on a vraiment on a peur que ce contrôle
d'abord parce à des mains de miliciens
ou autres qu'elles soient reprises par
des politiciens parce que les grandes
tensions politiques
aujourd'hui au liban et que soient
prises des deux côtés pour certains
fassent pression pour qu'il parte
gouvernement ou d'autres il doit faire
pression pour qui un gouvernant donc
c'est un peu de doute évidemment crise
sociale économique en grand et ça même
si les personnes qui ne sont pas sur la
rue il ya une très grande souffrance
énorme pour cette population
mais en même temps je peux vous dire que
les interférences politiques au cif sur
la rue pour faire pressions de part ou
d'autre
l'économie est en berne il ya aussi la
crise sanitaire puis l'explosion à
beyrouth qui a marqué les esprits mais à
quelques mois comment est ce qu'on le
paye peut sortir de fait empêche selon
vous écoutez si tu ne c'est une très
bonne question cdpa malheureusement ça
va être un bouton la première chose
c'est on ne peut pas commencer à on peut
pas commencer à sortir de l'impasse sans
avoir un gouvernement dans notre
constitution on a besoin d'un pouvoir
exécutif qui le pouvoir exécutif qui
prend les décisions d'abord et sur doux
et surtout qui peut aller négocier avec
le fonds monétaire international proposé
à blanc de sortie plan d'un plan de
restructuration
et c'est ça aujourd'hui le seul le seul
moyen donc je dirais premier point
évidemment un gouvernement
aujourd'hui qui est prêt à préparer
comme points
unique aujourd'hui c'est doit être le la
sortie de crise exactement c'est la
première chose est la deuxième source
aller directement au fonds monétaire
international pour pour discuter et
proposer un plan on n'a pas d'autre
solution de sortie de crise
sans une intervention je dirais
internationale qui va monétaire
économique social et je dirais même
politique parce que il faut bien dire et
je le dis à haute voix les personnes qui
ont causé ce désastre les personnes qui
ont causé ce chaos
les personnes qui sont entretués durant
quinze ans dans une guerre fratricide
ce sont exactement les mêmes qui ont
pris le pouvoir c'est exactement le même
qui ont complètement détruit le liban
économiquement et socialement ça ne peut
surtout pas être les mêmes qui vont le
reconstruire ou surtout faire face à
cette crise atypique
six mois après la démission du premier
ministre hassan diab où on en est où la
formation de ce gouvernement les
discussions patinent visiblement écouté
je dirais six mois après la démission
nous sommes même pas à la case départ
nous sommes à des cases bien bienne en
arrière parce que chaque jour on recule
d'un pas après la démission du
gouvernement hassan diab la nomination
du premier ministre hariri s'était très
rapidement donc on s'attendait quand
même à un gouvernement très rapide
c'était vraiment la promesse qui a été a
été fait et chaque jour de plus en plus
je pense qu'elle est ancion de tous les
partis politiques avec aucune volonté de
proposer à un gouvernement de nos jours
en même temps il faut dire qu'on subit
aussi des pressions internationales ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas un secret que
l'élection américaine le changement de
politique américain les tensions
iranienne dans la dans la région un peu
c'est à dire que nous avons des tensions
évidemment interne qui jouent un rôle
très grand mais nous avons aussi des
tensions régionales qui sont qui sont
bien connus et bien sûr des tensions
internationales avec le changement
d'administration donc je dis chaque jour
nous revenons d'un pack parce que nous
avons assisté à quelques jours je dirais
un défilé politique de plusieurs
protagonistes politiques qui chacun a
fait son discours mais dans tous les
discours qu'on a écouté c'était
simplement un gel qui va de plus en plus
est un problème et une je dirais une
licence d'un gouvernement et devient
quasi impossible dans cette situation
merci beaucoup pour votre témoignage
fois d'asthme au col je rappelle que
vous êtes
président du rassemblement des
dirigeants et chefs d'entreprise
libanais dans le monde